welcome to this video playing shushing
hike double 08 frequent opponent nine
wins nine losses and I have to go E 4
due to my opening challenge week cannot
go for d form which is probably not a
bad thing I kind of struggle in the
Queen's engine against the sky okay and
it's not playing okay so we got a
Sicilian and probably some kind of
Russell limo I don't know or be should
be five check unless he goes e six or a
six I'm going to put the bishop on b5
yep cancel got this chicken going to
check and go see form with the 70
tonight okay yeah after 97 s probably
also see three based setups that are
quite okay but I don't really mind the
maroc see white never never did that
always quite a nice opening for white I
think so let's get this get this going b
three yeah i'm yeah it was a bit shaky
there is a bit shaky 94 however this is
also strong meds and what is what he is
playing there so if i check there what
is he doing 94 94 and he allows me to
take that twice on d6 yeah so yeah okay
I'm I'm up for that
94 94 Bishop a 196 that is that is quite
dangerous for black check not going to
be subtle about that check and take NC
eight at the end is Bishop e3 check this
is a key point is here and she just wins
now black resigns that was nice it's
better than shuffling around in the
Queen's Indian for 10 minutes against
him yeah b5 was just not working good
game probably it is it is probably good
I think to take on b5 mp5 is probably
yeah it's really not working the comp is
giving I didn't see the move of course
and beforehand but Chad said said that
is just chatting for white he has no no
real defense to that check system the
key point and I'm two pawns are change
and and just the position up let's say
yeah with the better bishop and and
their tech still still raging on so um
yeah that was it was nice probably black
instead of this this drastic move can
play just know normal stuff of course
like let's say castles I don't know f3
maybe up it should be 386 f3 then then
normal no I should so I should pay
attention should cover that b5 was a
threat so this kind of thing is probably
happening a typical maroc see bind kind
of position that I'd like to play and
the good thing about this kind of thing
is if you could just think about the
same after here if you just want the
game this is this is very easy a you go
always c4 and d4 for the maroc see bind
and you can display chest from seven or
eight or something so it's a good
playable an opening line even if
don't know the the heavy theory stuff of
the open so you can play for something
it's just not it's not dull and
uninteresting but those Bishop b5 lines
can be played with some ideas so Goodwin
there thanks for watching